less than one man is dead after a
shooting near downtown las vegas this
happened on maryland parkway near carson
right now police are searching for two
suspects connected to the crime bianca
holman has our story
yellow tape surrounded the desert plaza
apartment complex near carson and
maryland parkway on sunday residents
called police around 8 in the morning
after hearing a gunshot when police
arrived they were directed to an open
door at an apartment they attempted to
give a man aid who was in his 30s or 40s
they located a black male who was
suffering from a gunshot wound medical
rise shortly thereafter and pronounced
that male deceased here on scene the
homicide unit will continue to
investigate gathering video evidence and
talking to witnesses while details are
still unknown as what led up to the
murder those living in the complex saw
potential suspects they saw two subjects
flee eastbound in an east round
direction of travel
and we believe it possibly be a male and
a female bianca holman live local now
l-v-m-p-d says if you have any tips
please call crime stoppers or you can
contact police the crime stoppers number
here on your screen and of course you
can remain anonymous